well one of Carrie's neighbors who chose
to remain anonymous just told the New
York Post that Kerry only presents as a
female in public in very specific public
situations the neighbor says he wears
prosthetic breasts extremely
infrequently he puts the breasts on to
teach occasionally when he goes for a
walk or when the cops visit but then
this this neighbor I suppose or one of
the neighbors got some photos of this
guy just walking around his neighborhood
and he's just walking around in sweats
and like a t-shirt and it just looks
like a completely normal guy to which I
say
don't hate the player hate the game if
this guy is trolling which he very well
might be is brilliant